One of the themes of the course.
Maybe the main thing with the course is the diversity's of early Christianity.
In fact,
a lot of scholars like to talk about not Christianity and the first 100 years,
but Christianity's,
this is one of the things also have Bart Ehrman's textbook.
So you should have picked up on this.
There's lots of different kinds of Christianity's and we'd be talking about
those kinds.
Right?
Today we get to one of the most interesting differences to most people because
most modern people are not at all familiar with the gospel of Thomas.
And so this the gospel of Thomas,
not in our cannon,
uh,
for several reasons,
but we can talk about that at some point.
At the end of the lecture,
if you want to know,
the gospel of Thomas has become very famous though in the 20th cent last part of
the 20th century because it was rediscovered and published and created something
of a sensation
according to the tradition.
According to the gospel of Thomas,
Jesus had a twin brother
and his name was Didymus Judas Thomas.
Now did hummus is simply the Greek word for twin.
Uh,
it's also used as the Greek word for testicles for obvious reasons.
There are usually two of them.
So it did it miss is the Greek word for twin.
And Thomas is from a Semitic word,
either Hebrew or Aramaic are Syriac,
which are all three similar languages.
Uh,
Thomas would look like twin in those.
So the,
the guy's name is Judas,
the Hebrew version would be Judah.
The Greek word would be Judas.
And the English version is Jude.
So you sometimes see it in English translations,
[inaudible],
Jude Thomas,
but this the same word,
Judah or Judas.
So his real name is Judah are Judas.
And he did a mess.
And Thomas are his nickname's one Greek and one,
uh,
submitted or Aramaic.
He was the twin brother of Jesus according to early Christian tradition.
Now just one strand of early Christian tradition that is Thomasin Christianity,
the forms of Christianity popular especially in Syria and the east,
which traced their existence back to the apostle Thomas.
So there really was an apostle Thomas among the 12 of Jesus' disciples.
And,
and,
uh,
and having that nickname twin,
traditional more traditional Orthodox Christians don't believe he was Jesus,
his twin brother.
They just believe that he had nicknamed nickname twin because he was somebody
else's twin brother.
But in Thomas,
in Christianity,
he was connected to Jesus himself as Jesus twin according to some forms of
eastern Christianity.
Therefore,
especially the early forms in Syria,
Mesopotamia and India.
And yes,
there was very,
very early forms of Christianity in the west coast of India.
They,
and if you meet a or an Indian person who's from that part of India and who
considered themselves Christian and they'd been Christian for generations and
generations,
they will tell you yes.
Thomas was the apostle who brought the gospel to India the first time.
So there are ancient traditions about this and modern see Indian Christians,
uh,
still,
trace their,
their,
their church back to the apostle Thomas.
There are all kinds of Thomas literature from the ancient world.
It's,
it's,
it's not all like,
it doesn't all represent one kind of Christianity are one church or even one
region.
But among,
besides the gospel of Thomas,
we know of the Infancy Gospel of Thomas.
This is a wonderful document.
If you took my historical Jesus class,
you get to read the fragments of the Infancy Gospel of Thomas that we still
have.
And it shows you everybody wonders,
well,
what was Jesus like as a kid?
You know,
what games did you play?
Did he play cops and robbers?
Did he play with dolls?
You know,
what did you use to as a kid?
Will Thomas tells you,
it tells you,
for example,
that he made a bunch of clay pigeons.
And when this,
uh,
ju,
it's kind of an anti Jewish document,
this juke comes up and says,
you're not supposed to be doing that on the Sabbath.
So Jesus claps his hands and the pigeons all fly off the clay pigeons by off,
or I went to one of his buddies,
uh,
get he gets mad at his buddies.
So he,
uh,
strikes the kid dead and then it has to raise the kid up again.
Uh,
when one of his teeth,
when one of his teachers criticizes him,
he says,
what do you know?
You've Bimbo and strikes the teacher dumb and blind or something.
It was like Jesus has a little kid in the gospel of Thomas in the Infancy Gospel
of Thomas is kind of a little rat,
but um,
that's the way people imagined him as a child.
So there's the infancy gospel of Thomas.
There's the acts of Thomas,
which are very interesting.
Thomas comes across as very anti marriage antifamily there's the hymn of the
Pearl or the him is as,
it's also called the hymn of Jude Thomas,
the apostle in the country of the Indians.
Same document,
we tend to call it the hem of the Pearl.
There's a,
the book of Thomas The contender riding to the perfect.
So all of these different texts sprang up in early Christianity,
most of them in the second century.
The second century was a time of a lot of Christian literature arising in
different places that didn't make it into the Bible
before.
The discovery though of the non commodity codices you probably already know how
to spell nod commodity because you've seen it in your textbook.
It's just the name of a village in modern Egypt.
I don't remember how many eyes and D's and F's and D's.
It has something like that.
That's that right.
Dylan,
who is our,
one of our teaching assistants,
he's an expert on all this stuff so he can correct me.
Uh,
not commodity is a village in Egypt.
And in 1945,
while they were digging for some clay and that sort of thing,
uh,
son Egyptian peasant found a 13 large books.
Remember the word codecs or Codices I've talked about in the,
uh,
one of the early lectures means the kind of book that has,
the pate has pages and on all sewn up on one side to distinguish it from a book
that's in a scroll form.
So this by this time you found these books,
they had been buried there probably some time in the fourth century,
so in the three hundreds and they'd probably been hidden there because that's
about the time that certain forms of Christianity we're being outlawed and
declared heretical.
There are 13 of these big books and Rod is rod along the Nile River and we call
these the nod commodity library or the not commodity corpus,
the knock body text.
That's just because the modern village near where they were found is not
commodity before this 1945 discovery and the gospel of Thomas is one of many,
many different texts that were discovered in this library of material.
Before this,
we knew that there was a gospel of Thomas because early Christian writers would
talk about it usually to condemn it and we did.
We had a few papayas fragments,
three pirates fragments that had Greek versions of just parts of the gospel of
Thomas,
just pieces of it from oxy,
oxy,
Rinkus Egypt.
But the non commodity discovery was really a very,
very exciting because it greatly increased our knowledge of some forms of
Christianity that the only thing we had known about them was by Orthodox a
writers condemning it.
And you know,
in Orthodox when one kind of writers condemning another,
a bunch of people,
you can't necessarily trust what they say.
Orthodox writers for example,
claim that Gnostics,
who they took to be the these heritage,
they were,
we would talk about gnosticism in this lecture.
They said,
oh,
they have these wild sex orgies and they,
uh,
they drink blood and they have cannibalism.
Well,
uh,
regular Christians were accused by their enemies of doing precisely the same
thing.
So we don't believe everything.
But when we found these non-commodity texts,
we had sort of firsthand texts from these people who understood Christianity
differently than what would come to be,
um,
Orthodox Christianity.
Now,
the modern study of Gnosticism,
uh,
therefore has been completely revolutionized by this study because it brought to
light a complete version of the gospel of Thomas,
although it was in Coptic translation of the Greek.
It was originally written in Greek,
translated into Coptic,
which is an ancient Egyptian language,
but it also brought to light all these other texts,
not all by the same people,
not all reflecting the same views.
Some of them,
for example,
are just pieces of Plato are parts of the Bible and that sort of thing.
These texts I said were the texts we actually have and not commodity.
Codices were,
were written around the time three 50.
And we know this because the cardboard that was used to bind these things was
made at a papyrus fragments and paper fragments.
They were older.
So by,
by dating some of the,
the pieces of paper that were used to make the cardboard that bound these
things,
we can tell when the,
at least these books were put together.
Um,
but we think that a lot of these texts were actually written in the second
century and the Gospel of Thomas,
most scholars would say is written the year 200.
Some scholars believe that the gospel of Thomas goes all the way back to the
first century and may even be as early as mark or Q or even earlier.
I think probably the majority of scholars don't believe that.
I think the majority of us believe that the gospel of Thomas was probably first
written in Greek,
uh,
in the first half of the second century.
So between 101 50,
but we don't really know.
It's a,
just a complete guess.
Some of the sayings in the gospel of Thomas,
um,
look,
actually older Bart Ehrman talks about why you would think a certain,
uh,
saying in one form might be older than us saying in another form.
Uh,
and that's debatable,
but some of us,
if we just compare the same side by side,
those in the gospel of Thomas to some people would say,
well this looks actually like an older version of this saying or of Jesus or an
older version of a,
of a parable of Jesus that we find in Matthew our mark.
And so some people have said,
and even if the gospel of Thomas itself comes from the second century,
it may well contain what are more ancient versions of sayings of Jesus.
This is why when people do historical Jesus research that is trying to figure
out from the multiple gospels that we have,
what did the historical Jesus really say and really do historically determined.
People will use the gospel of Thomas sometimes to say,
well,
this is actually more likely what Jesus actually close to what Jesus actually
said.
And the Canonical Gospel writers have edited it up a bit.
So that's,
it's very debatable about that.
But that's a part of the value of the gospel of Thomas is that for a lot of
scholars,
we believe it takes us back at least a close to the time of Jesus in some of its
sayings,
but not necessarily in all of it.
Sings.
There are 114 sayings as you buy now knowing the gospel of commerce.
And as I said last time,
scholars like to use two bit words when one bit words would do just as well.
So instead of calling these sayings,
you will often see them called logia.
That's the plural Logue.
Aeon is the singular.
Logan is just Greek for a saying.
So logia is just great for sayings.
So often in scholarship in your textbooks,
sometimes it'll say loogie on one 14 from the gospel of Thomas and that just
means saying one 14 there are 114 of them and in fact they're introduced.
The Gospel is introduced by just the words.
These are the obscure or the hidden sayings that the living Jesus uttered and
which did [inaudible] Jude Thomas wrote down.
So it gives you sort of,
it's a little title right there.
At the beginning.
Notice there's no passion narrative.
There's no description of the death of Jesus.
There is no resurrection and actually most people would think that Jesus speaks
as if he's already been resurrected.
So does this author intend us to think that this is the post resurrection Jesus
or did he just assume that even before his death,
Jesus just talked to this way?
You have to use your imagination because the author doesn't really tell us.
Now comparisons with other gospels,
get out your text.
You're a gospel of Thomas and read with me through some of these things.
Look at logix on nine this is the parable of the sower.
Jesus said,
listen,
a sower came forth,
took a handful and cast.
Now some fell on from the pathway and the birds came and pick them out.
Others fell on a rock,
but they did not take root in the soil and did not send up years.
Others fell upon the thorns and they choke the seat and the grubs devoured them
and others fell upon good soil and it sent up good crops and you'll do 60 per
measure and 120 per measure.
That's actually an example of when you have a saying that sounds on more
primitive perhaps in this gospel,
because notice how that saying is shorter and a bit simpler than the same
parable would be in either Matthew or Luke.
An example of why some people say,
well,
maybe it's more primitive.
That one sounds very,
very much like what you've got already in the canonical gospels.
So it should found,
sound familiar to you?
Look at the number eight right above that.
What human beings resemble is an intelligent fishermen who having cast his net
into the sea,
pulled up the net out of the sea full of little fish,
the intelligent fishermen upon finding among them,
uh,
find large fish through all the little fish back into the sea,
choosing without any effort,
the big fish,
whoever has ears to hear should listen.
Now,
this translation I'm reading from Bentley Leighton's translation,
he's a professor in our department.
He's a very famous as one of the top cop technologists in the world.
And so I'm using his translation of this,
uh,
and but that whoever has ears to hear should listen even though the translation
makes it sound slightly different.
That's just exactly the same thing as you see in the gospels.
Let Him who have ears to hear here late and just decided to translate it in a
bit more colloquial English version.
So that's just like what you would find practically in the other gospels looking
30 saying 30
Jesus said,
where there are three divine beings,
they are divine.
Where there are two or one,
I myself dwell with that person.
That sounds of it more odd,
doesn't it?
It sounds a bit like a saying of Jesus in the gospels that says wherever two or
three are gathered together,
I am there in the midst of them.
But what does this about divine beings where there are three divine beings,
they are divine.
Where there are two or one,
I myself dwell with that person.
It's puzzle.
You can tell how it's similar,
but not exactly like this.
The synoptic gospels look at Verse 48.
Jesus said,
if to make peace with one another within a single house,
they will say to a mountain,
go elsewhere and it will go elsewhere.
Does it remind me what the synoptic version of that saying says,
anybody
know your Bible well enough?
Yes sir.
Yeah,
that's right.
If you have faith size of a mustard seed,
the size of a mustard seed,
you can tell a mountain to remove yourself and I'll go.
So it's a,
it's in this,
this thing that,
um,
to making peace again,
uh,
with one another within a house so that it's the peacemaking making that seems
to give the power.
Um,
86.
Okay.
Jesus said foxes have their dens and birds have their nests,
but the son of man has nowhere to lay his head and gain repose.
Now that sounds funny.
Up until the last couple of words,
it sounded just like the synoptic gospels,
but this at least lateness translated and then just say and get rest and rest.
Lay his head in.
Rest.
Professor Layton,
his for some reason translated this to sound a bit odd and gain repose.
I think what that means is he's trying to signal that this,
these last two words have some kind of special meaning for this author in this
text.
What kind of special meeting would that be and then one 13 these are just
examples of sayings that looked very much like what we already have seen in the
Bible.
His disciples said to him,
when is the kingdom going to come?
Now we've got this in the gospels also in the Bible.
Jesus said it is not by being waited for that it's going to come.
They are not going to say,
here it is are there it is rather the kingdom of the father is spread out over
the earth and people do not see it.
This is not the kingdom coming in the future as we've seen it in mark and
Matthew and Luke,
this is the kingdom is already here on the earth and if you don't know that it's
just because you aren't recognizing it.
There are though really interesting peculiarities or the gospel of Thomas.
And let's look at some of those first look at 13 these are some sayings that
look more odd to us.
Jesus said to his disciples,
compare me to something and tell me what I resemble.
This starting off sounding like what we've seen already,
Simon Peter said,
hey,
just angel is whom you resemble.
Matthew said to him and intelligent philosopher is what you resemble.
Thomas said to him,
teacher,
my mouth utterly will not let me say what you resemble.
Jesus said,
I am not your teacher for you.
Now notice he lightens letting you know.
Are you using the same translation that I am?
That's right.
I thought I gave you the same translation.
Leighton says,
let you know because you can't tell an English whether that your teacher is
singular.
You are plural you.
And he tells you it's singular in the Coptic.
I am not your teacher.
So Jesus is directing this,
not to all the apostles,
but to Thomas in particular,
right here for you,
have drunk and become intoxicated from the bubbling wellspring that I have
personally measured out.
Well,
what the hell does that mean?
And he took him that took Thomas with drew and said three things to him.
Now when Thomas came to his companions,
they asked him,
what did Jesus say to you?
Thomas said to them,
if I say to you,
plural,
one of the things that he said to me,
you will take stones and stone me and fire will come out of the stones and burn
you up.
Sort of an ancient version of I'd tell you,
but then I'd have to kill you.
Okay,
look at 29
Jesus said,
it is amazing if it was for the spirit that flesh came into existence and it is
amazing indeed,
if spirit came into existence for the sake of the body.
But as for me,
I am amazed at how this great wealth has come to dwell in this poverty.
What does that mean?
Look at the very last saying,
I hope some of you noticed this when you're reading over this.
Before he came to class,
Simon Peter said to them,
Mary should leave us.
He's talking about Mary Magdalen probably from females are not worthy of life.
Jesus said,
see,
I am going to attract her to make her mail so that she too might become a living
spirit that resembles you.
Males for every female that makes itself mail will enter the Kingdom of heaven.
Oh,
okay.
Look at 24
I'm just picking out some sayings that are rather mysterious.
His disciples said,
show us the place where you are for we must seek it.
He said to them,
whoever has ears should listen.
There is light existing within a person of light and it enlightens the whole
world.
If it does not enlighten,
that person is darkness.
The previous saying had this duality of male and female that was somehow
significant in some mysterious way.
This one shows us,
there's,
there's also a duality of concern to this author of light and darkness.
So there's dualisms and especially a light darkness dualism,
male,
female dualism and a soul body dualism.
We've already seen that.
Uh,
there's also this word that latent translates as the entirety and some modern
translations will just leave it.
They'll just transliterate the Greek that it's from.
Pleroma.
Pleroma is a Greek word that comes in part and in some philosophy in the ancient
world and some intellectual and it just means the all or the fullness,
but it comes,
it's an abstract where meaningful or fullness,
but it comes to be some kind of technical term that refers to,
I don't know,
all of existence or the fullness of being or like think of German philosophy
with fullness,
with a cap being with a capital B,
our existence with a capital e.
So that word is often occurs here and when you see the word entirety and
Leighton's translation,
he's translated that word play Roman.
Jesus said,
and this is 67 if anyone should become acquainted with the entirety the pleroma
and should fall short and all that fought person fall short,
utterly several other places saying 77 another reference to that.
Notice we've already seen that this text does not take the Kingdom of God is
something existing in the future.
In fact,
this text is not at all eschatological.
Remember we encountered this word in previous lecture,
which really just means something having to do with the end as gotten in Greek.
Meaning the end.
This author is not eschatological.
He doesn't think Christianity has had this.
Think Jesus's teachings are about the future at all.
They're about now,
there are about to present.
So there are several sayings in Thomas.
Unlike the sayings in the Gospels and the Canon that are not eschatological,
they've very much pointed the present.
There's also something else.
One of this,
this or this author is concerned about something like integration.
Look at saying 61 Jesus said to wil rose repos on a couch,
one will die,
one will live.
Salome said,
who are you?
Oh man,
like a stranger.
You have gotten upon my couch and you have eaten from my table.
Jesus said to her,
it is I who come from that which is integrated.
I,
I come from that which is one.
I come from that which is not divided.
I was given some of the things that my father,
she apparently,
there's a lot of holes in the text where you see those.dot,
dots and that's showing that there are lacunae that is just holes in the,
in the actual document that Layton that we get this from.
So there are gaps in the text.
I am your female disciple.
She's used to say to him at some point,
and then eventually he seems to answer.
Therefore,
I say that such a person once integrated will become full of light,
but such a press person wants divided will become full of darkness.
So there's a divided integrated dualism that's going on in this text also.
Uh,
the kingdom is invisible.
I think I've already pointed this out.
The idea is that the kingdom is not something you say,
look,
it's over there and look,
it's here.
Uh,
one 13.
I've already read that.
Uh,
the Kingdom of fathers spread it over the earth,
but most people don't see it.
And then look at saying three right at the very beginning,
Jesus said,
if those who lead you say to you,
see the kingdom is in heaven,
then the birds of Heaven will precede you.
If they say to you it is in the sea,
then the fish will proceed you.
But the kingdom is inside of you and it is outside of you.
When you become acquainted with yourself.
Now,
the word acquainted here means when you become really knowledgeable and it comes
from the Greek word here is gnosis where we get the term gnostics.
That Greek word means gnosis but it does,
it means gnosis in uh,
in,
uh,
in some kinds of technical way in these document,
which is,
it's not something you just know with your head.
It's something you really,
really know.
And so it,
to express that,
uh,
Professor Layton usually translates this word as acquaintance or becoming
acquainted with it.
When you become acquainted with yourselves,
then you will be recognized and you will understand that it is you who are
children of the living father.
But if you do not become acquainted with yourself,
if you don't have gnosis of yourself,
then you are in poverty and it is you who are the poverty?
What is all this going on?
These things are things that sound a bit familiar and we might be able to figure
them out because these are themes.
You can tell that there are things of light and darkness,
poor and riches,
uh,
inside and out,
soul and body,
spirit and body,
uh,
male and female.
But there are some songs that are just really inscrutable.
Look at saying seven.
Jesus said bless.
It is the lion that the human being will devour so that the lion becomes human
and curse.
It is the human being that the lion of devours and the lion will become human.
What does that mean?
I have no clue and that's really honest.
Look at 15
okay.
Jesus said,
when you and here's a plural,
you see one who has not been born of woman fall upon your faces and prostate,
your prostrate yourselves before that one.
It is that one.
Who is your father?
Someone not born of women.
Is Your father 97
okay.
Yeah.
You see,
aren't you glad that I didn't make you do an extra Jesus paper of these things?
Jesus said what the Kingdom of the father resembles is a woman who was conveying
a jar full of meal when she had traveled far along the road,
the handle,
the jar broke and the meal spilled out after her along the road.
She was not aware of the fact that she had not understood how to toil.
When she reached home.
She put down the jar and found it empty.
How profound.
Jesus,
she lost her meal and she found her jar empty when she got home.
Okay?
98 right below that,
Jesus said,
what the king or the father resembles is a man who wanted to assassinate a
member of court at home.
He drew the dagger and stabbed it into the wall in order to know whether his
hand would be from next.
He murdered the member of court.
That's what the kingdom is like.
Now you know exactly what the kingdom is like,
right?
One Oh five
Jesus said whoever is acquainted with the father and the mother will be called
the offspring of a prostitute.
Great.
All right.
What's going on here?
This document has called and still causes all kinds of debate among scholars.
You could go online right now and you will see tons and tons and tons of stuff
written about the gospel of Thomas,
some by real scholars and intelligent wise people like me.
Although I've actually never written by the gospel of Thomas Cause I don't want
to go that get in that mess.
But I have good scholarly friends who publish on the gospel of Thomas and argue
their theories,
others by just absolute Kooks who are using the gospel of Thomas for all kinds
of experimental spirituality and religion and you know,
mind stuff.
I'm trying to watch my language.
So,
but then you'll also have,
even if you took very reputable scholars,
you will have why differences of opinion and one of the big differences of
opinion right now when when the gospel comes first became published,
people sort of talking about it is,
oh,
this is a gnostic gospel.
It represents a form of GNOSTICISM,
which I'll explain in a moment.
Other people have said,
no,
it's not gnostic.
It doesn't have all the main things we look for.
In fact,
they even said we shouldn't even use this term gnosticism anymore because it
doesn't refer to anything we can actually locate in the ancient world.
It refers to a whole bunch different things and nobody could come up with a good
definition of gnosticism or the GNOSTIC church.
So scholars right now,
some scholars will say,
let's get rid of the term entirely and call it something else.
Whatever it is.
This thing is others continued to use the term Bart Ehrman wrote your textbook
if you'll notice,
he goes ahead and sort of takes the gospel of Thomas as representing some kind
of gnosticism.
Um,
but maybe not all of them,
whatever we would call gnosticism.
And he admits that there's a big debate.
Now I'm going to a little bit of terminology.
I've already told you what not.
The term gnostic comes from this word gnosis and the word gnostic cause was used
by some people in the ancient world to refer to themselves,
but they didn't necessarily mean by that,
that they were in some kind of sect called gnosticism.
For example,
the Clement of Alexandria who wrote around the year 200,
a very famous,
uh,
early Christian scholar considered by later Christianity to be perfectly
orthodox.
He talked about gnostic Christians and thought he was himself a gnostic
Christian.
And what he meant by that apparently was just that he was one of the more
knowledgeable,
he was one more why as Christians he was in the know and he seems also to have
had an idea that there were two kinds of Christian knowledge.
There's public knowledge that all Christians have and then there's special kind
of hidden knowledge,
esoteric knowledge that only certain kinds of Christians have.
And so this idea that you have esoteric knowledge would be called a gnostic kind
of notion.
So there are even Orthodox Christians who might use the term gnostic in the
second century to refer even to themselves.
So that's just what that word,
that word gnostic often meant.
It would've looked a bit weird to an ancient Greek speaker,
but it would have been,
uh,
it would have been understandable as simply unknowing person.
There are other terms though that I want to talk about.
I've already mentioned,
I believe the term pro tow orthodox.
Yeah.
The word Orthodox,
of course just means right thinking,
right opinion Ortho from Greek,
right or true or correct or straight doxa meaning opinion or thoughts or are
then it comes to mean doctrine to the problem with using the word Orthodox.
Is that the opposite of Orthodox?
It's usually Harrison.
Okay.
In this and eventually,
uh,
through different church councils and the fourth and fifth and sixth centuries,
what counted as Orthodox Christianity became more clearly defined and then
anything that wasn't,
that can be labeled heretical Christianity.
And it was even outlawed at different times and late antiquity.
So for example,
the Nicene creed that proclaims that the trend,
the doctrine of the trinity becomes Orthodox doctrines that say that the trinity
is not true or that there's not the holy spirit and NGS and other are not
Orthodox.
They're heretical are sometimes you'll see the term Hetero docs.
Yeah.
Hetero just means other.
So it's,
it's not Ortho,
it's other.
So Orthodox though the problem is we can't read traject that term easily back
into the second century because in the second century that there are tons of
different Christians and tons of different churches that had many different
views and they didn't all agree there are some people heads were started
experimenting with the doctrine of the trinity,
but a lot of Christians wouldn't have recognized the doctrine of the trinity in
the second century.
Some people believe that Jesus was fully divine,
other pleased that people really know he was fully human but not divine.
Some people believed he was both.
Some people do who was a mixture of both.
Some believe that sometimes it was one,
sometimes it was the other.
We'll come back to this issue of,
of of what do people believe Jesus was and that's the doctrine of Christology.
What do you believe about Christ?
But right now I'm just going to tell you that the pro that we call,
we call Christians and the SEC second century and the first entry pro tow
orthodox because we don't,
we know that condom orthodox is anachronistic in this time because there wasn't
to clearly delineate ball Orthodox and heretical,
uh,
groups or churches.
W Protoje just means earlier then are the first.
So a lot of scholars,
Bart Ehrman is one of them,
uses this term pro tow orthodox and all it means is those Christians living in
the first or second century who,
whose views happened to win out.
Eventually they happen to hold views that would eventually be the winners and
the fight between Orthodoxy and heresy and be declared Orthodox or correct
Christianity.
So pro to Orthodox.
There was no Christian running around in the second century calling himself a
pro tow Orthodox Christian.
They didn't know they were pro to orthodox yet.
They,
but their views eventually won out.
So these different terms,
we'll come over and over again.
Protal orthodox just means someone who sort of had correct christological views
that is correct by later standards,
but they held them before these standards had one out in the debate.
Ancient Gnosticism,
if you want to call it that,
does not seem to have been one church.
What I'm going to call gnosticism is an movement that seems to have been around
beginning in the second century,
certainly and becomes important through the second,
third,
and fourth centuries.
It's not a church and our institution in the sense that we doubt that you could
have walked into say,
the town of Antioch and looked for the the GNOSTIC church.
Yeah.
It seems like the people who wrote these documents and collected these materials
that we find in the Nakematte texts and the gospel of Thomas,
they seem to have been intellectuals who are impressed with Jesus,
impressed with the,
uh,
Jewish scripture and a lot of cases impressed with a lot of the teachings of
Christianity,
but they interpreted them through the eyes of a certain popular Platonism at the
time.
That is,
they seem to have been influenced by different philosophical views and also just
different intellectual views.
So when they read the,
the book of Genesis,
for example,
they would read the book of Genesis,
but read it as if they were reading it through the eyes of Plato's Timaeus,
the great platonic dialogue in which Plato puts forth his own sort of a
cosmology and his own view of,
of the gods and the world.
So it sounds,
some of their writing sound like they were reading basically good scripture,
but reading it through the eyes of certain kinds of philosophy.
Yeah.
And so what we've come to call gnosticism and the ancient world is a range of
ideas that may have been actually embodied in particular people or it may have
been that some of these just intellectual shutters of playing around with ideas
and writing them up and books and having reading clubs where they got together
every Monday night,
you know,
and drank some beer and uh,
uh,
talked about their gnostic ideas.
Platonism itself might be called pro tow gnostic.
That is gnosticism before gnosticism.
Okay.
Uh,
for example,
in Platonism,
especially at this time,
you have a strong emphasis of a dualism of body and soul,
our body and spirit.
And in that dualism,
often the body or the materiality,
the fleshly existence,
the harder matter of things becomes less good.
Sometimes even probably bordering on evil.
And some people thought and spirit or the soul or the mind is the good thing.
So you have a mind,
body dualism,
uh,
of body and soul dualism.
And often there's the deprecation of the body and a deprecation of matter as
morally inferior.
Now,
why would matter be considered inferior to non material substance?
Because,
uh,
what happens to your body eventually?
You all have gorgeous bodies now,
but eventually you're going to look like me.
Your hair's gonna fall out.
Your ears is going to get too big,
your nose won't stop growing.
And then eventually you'll get even get beyond me and you'll die and you'll rot
and you'll disappear.
The body is material and the ancient thinkers all knew that matter passes away.
Anything that is material is going to pass away and be destroyed and be gone.
But things that are not material like ideas,
an idea.
The great thing about an idea is that it never need die.
So the spirit of the soul and platonic theory was superior to material stuff
because,
and it was the only thing that could live forever,
be an infinite.
They also,
sometimes you see,
especially in later Platonism the idea that not only is the,
is the body temporary,
not eternal and passing away,
but the body is also a prison because your spirit,
they believed,
wants to get out of the body.
Aren't you frustrated that you can't just escape your body and go off and go
someplace else for a while and,
and zoom out of your body and go to Argentina for the weekend?
You know,
not have to pay for airfare or,
so the idea was that the body in prisons,
your spirit and your soul,
and this has come to be a part of Platonism at the time.
So what scholars will call basic gnosticism includes some basic themes that they
hold in common first,
the world itself,
which is material is evil.
Salvation,
therefore from the world must be escape from this physical world into something
else.
Gross materiality is not only temporary in some texts,
but even bad.
It's evil
and salvation therefore must be the knowledge of how you,
that is the real you,
your brain,
you're up me,
not your brain,
your mind or your soul,
your spirit,
not your body.
That real you is existing in this material body that salvation will be if it can
learn how to escape the body and escape materiality,
that salvation would come by knowledge and that knowledge is a secret.
Not everybody knows it,
so only a few people know it.
The content of this knowledge is related to human origins and destination,
so sometimes you get this Ilab,
these elaborate myths developed in some of these texts.
Let's say that the Supreme Supreme Supreme Supreme God is,
has no name is not a particular thing.
It's this thought.
It's just thinking.
It's just abstract thinking that thinking thinks well,
what does a thinking thing think?
The thinking thinks thoughts.
Those thoughts start becoming emanations out of the thinking and in those
emanations think and emanate.
And those become lesser being still.
And these.
So the different divine beings,
there are lots of divine beings of the distant universe and they,
by thinking and being,
they eliminate inferior forms of being after themselves.
And eventually what happened is those in fear of forms of being get less good
and less like the most ultimate being.
And one of them,
according to one myth,
Sophia,
which needs wisdom,
it's a female name,
but it also means wisdom.
Sophia decides she wants to emanate and she supposed to do that with a male
concert because by this time and these beings have male and female versions of
themselves,
she's supposed to only emanate or procreate by doing so with her male consort,
she decides she wants to be like the Supreme God and be able to emanate on her
own.
So she puts out of being on her own.
And in other words,
she sort of gives birth without needing a man.
Just the DVM pendulum.
Well of course when you do that,
you end up with a monster.
So the being that came out of Sophia ended up being a clumsy,
maybe evil,
God.
These,
all of these are divine beings that God decided at some point he wanted to
create things and so he,
he didn't really do it very well.
So he made our earth.
He made the worlds.
We know it.
He made little human beings like you just have of dirt and clay,
and that's why you know we were,
we were all creation,
not of the Supreme God who would do nothing imperfect,
but if some stumbling or evil,
at least clumsy God who made us.
That explains why things go wrong.
Why is it my arthritis acts up all the time?
Couldn't God have made a human body that didn't have arthritis?
Well,
that's because the Supreme God didn't make this body the evil,
clumsy.
God made the body.
This happened and so the the world that we created,
when you read in Genesis,
it says,
God created the world.
That's not the highest God.
That's some clumsy God down further on the hierarchy of divine beings in the
universe that God created what we are.
Now.
What happened was at some point,
either Sophia or some other bangs,
they got,
sorry for all of us.
Clay like mud,
mud people,
and somehow a little spark of the divine itself either fell down or got cut up
or put in our bodies.
Our God placed antibodies are blue into our bodies,
but at least some human beings,
all human beings,
in fact,
human beings are in different categories.
There's,
you know,
the really low human beings like undergraduates.
Then there are beings who are a little bit higher like graduate students and
then you had the supreme beings,
gnostics,
like professors.
So the true Gnostics,
so you don't ever,
it's not really like undergraduate and graduate stuff because some of you could
be gnostics.
You would be the ones who really have a real spark in us.
Spark of the divine.
That spark of the divine wants to escape the mud body that is trapped in,
but you probably don't even know that you're a really a spark trapped in a mud
body until somebody comes along and tells you,
and that's the job of the redeemer.
That's what Jesus did.
Jesus was a redeemer from the Supreme God who comes in to find those people who
have a spark of the divine in them to blow on that spark,
to get it going and to get you to remember where you came from.
You're not a mud body after all.
The real you came from God self,
God's various self,
the Supreme God.
So the true message of Christianity according to these guys is to learn who you
are,
where you came from,
to tis.
You can escape the body and get back to your true origin.
That is you will become one with God again.
And this was expressing a poem by Thea dotas and went like this,
who we were,
what we have become,
where we were,
whether we were thrown,
whether we are hastening from what we are redeemed,
what birth is,
what rebirth is.
Okay,
now you answered the riddle.
It's a poem riddle,
who we were.
If you're a gnostic,
who were you?
Answer for you on divine beings.
Thank you.
See,
it's not hard.
I'm not answering questions.
I'm just trying.
You'll remember this better.
If you answer what have you become mud and trapped in a dead body and trapped in
materiality.
Where were you?
Heaven with the divine father,
with God,
whether we were thrown.
Where have you been thrown into the earth,
into the world,
into materiality?
Where are you hastening where are you going in a hurt,
in such a hurry,
you're going back to the divine God.
What are you redeemed from
your dean,
from Jesus and material world.
You're redeemed from being embodied.
Uh,
what is birth
in this system?
What does birth,
damnation,
death?
When you're born,
your spark isn't trapped in your body.
That's not a good thing.
You shouldn't be celebrating your birthday for crying out loud.
That's like celebrating when you were thrown in prison.
And what is rebirth
death are learning your true self.
Learning that you,
the true south won't die at all.
So this learning is your rebirth.
So the little poem is a riddle that can,
contains these doctrines,
uh,
within itself.
So here's the true self.
The spark of light is trapped in an alien body with all its central passions.
Sex.
Therefore essential desire.
Erotic desire is a bad thing as an evil thing because that you're just trying to
trap more sparks into more mud bodies.
You're just creating more sparks trapped in mud bodies.
When you have sex,
evil powers exist.
All the different gods that were eliminated,
a bunch of those are evil and they fly around the sky in the heavens and they
did.
They try to keep the true self asleep or drunk in order to keep the evil world
together and their words,
they don't want you to learn and they don't want your spark to be able to fly
through.
But really wise guys like me,
we have the secrets and I can give you words,
clues,
secrets that you,
if you know those things,
you can use these secrets to unlock the gates that lead back to God.
So this is kind of a common storyline or myth.
There's a hammer,
the pearl that I mentioned before,
which basically tells this that a king of the east sins,
a royal prince by way of the region.
I'm a CNA to Egypt in order to get a precious Pearl,
which was being guarded by fierce dragon.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's like of like a video game,
right?
The prince is poisoned or actually drugged would be a better accurate
translation and made intoxicated by the Egyptians.
But he,
the prince is awakened by a message from the king.
He,
the prince takes the Pearl by defeating the dragon with the name of his father
and returns to the east where he puts on a robe of knowledge gnosis and ascends
to the king palace entering the realm of peace and living happily forever after.
It's a nice little fable about a prince who goes to a foreign land,
finds the thing of value,
defeats the evil purposes and goes back.
So some people therefore have read the gospel of Thomas as being precisely this
kind of,
uh,
that some of the sayings,
the gospel of Thomas makes sense if you presuppose these mythological structures
and ideas.
And again,
some scholars would say,
well you're just putting together as a modern scholar,
a bunch of disparate kinds of texts and ideas and putting it in a system.
Well,
yes,
that that's where I disagree with some people cause I want to say I believe that
there's enough commonalities between enough documents.
Then we can say that there were people who had these kinds of common ideas and
this basic structure that I've called the gnostic structure,
the gnostic myth certainly influenced ancient writings of some sort and it's,
and there was some kinds of Christianity there were heavily influenced by this.
So for example,
look at back to Thomas for our last closing minutes and let's read some of these
sayings that sound puzzling to us.
And if we understand,
we assume this myth,
maybe we'll read them differently.
Look at 21 [inaudible] Mary said to Jesus,
what do your disciples resemble?
He said,
what?
They resemble his children living in a plot of land that is not theirs.
When the owners of the land come,
they will say,
surrender our land to us.
They for their parts strip naked in their presence in order to give it back to
them and they give them back their land.
An Alec.
Nick could be an allegory.
Who are the owners of the land,
the evil powers that rule the earth?
Who are the children?
Who are the real disciples of Jesus?
Those people who know enough to say,
when the earth is demanded of you,
when your body is demanded of you by these evil powers,
give it up.
Just give it.
It's not valuable.
Anyway,
look at
his disciples said,
show us the place where you are for we must seek it.
He said that whoever has ears should listen.
There is a light existing within a person of light,
edited,
lightens the whole world.
If it does not enlighten,
that person is darkness.
Remember how I said some people are just dark people,
they're just mud people,
but some people have a light in them and what it means to become a true gnostic
is to note to learn that you are one who has that light
his disciples said,
when will you be shown forth to us?
And when shall we behold you?
Jesus said,
when you strip naked without being ashamed and take your garments and put them
under your feet like little children and tread upon them,
then you will see the child of the living and you will not be afraid.
Okay?
What's the gnostic interpretation of that?
Stripping the material world off yourself.
When you strip your soul,
your spot,
your spark of the body.
When you realize that it's not the real you and you come to know the real you,
that's what's going to happen.
Jesus said,
whoever has become acquainted with the world has found a corpse and the world is
not worthy of the one who has found the corpse.
The world is just a the dead body.
So all of these there,
several of the sayings,
if you go back to the gospel of Thomas with some of this background information,
I've given you these ancient myths and ideas.
Some of these sayings seem to fit the that myth and fit that notion.
There are other things though about what I've just told you that you don't find
in the gospel of Thomas.
And those are the things emphasized by people who say the gospel of Thomas
shouldn't be called gnostic.
For example.
There's no mention in here of an evil God that creates the world like you find
in some of these knock Hammadi texts.
You have the father,
you have apparently the good guy,
you have Jesus,
but there's not,
there's no emphasis on creation here as being a bad thing.
So some people have said that's,
that's one of the fundamental things about the gnostic gnostic miss,
and it's not in the gospel of Thomas.
Therefore the gospel of Thomas is a not gnostic.
They're also simply no string of myths and evil God's names,
which you often find in the text nakematte.
So some scholars would say the gospel of Thomas May have some things in common
with Platonism of at the time,
maybe when something come with certain Gnostics,
but it itself is not.
But if you take the gospel of Thomas as representing those ideas,
then Jesus comes across the Christology of the gospel of Thomas,
becomes something different from the histology of the other texts or at least
Matthew,
mark and Luke.
As we'll see,
the gospel of John Looks a lot more like this in the synoptic gospels dead.
But Jesus becomes this redeemer figure,
this gnostic redeemer figure who comes into the world of materiality in order to
find those who have sparks of life to blow on their sparks of light to transmit
hidden knowledge of them so they can get back.
And if you'll stay with me the rest of the semester,
maybe I can give you those secrets and you can escape your mud bodies too.
All right,
you have your,
your uh,
sections this week.
By tomorrow they'll be up way on online classes server and uh,
the different instructions for the rest of the sections.
And you'll need to look at that because at your section on Thursday or Friday,
y'all need to choose which day and which topic you'll do your paper for.
So that will be online by tomorrow morning.
Thank you.
See you next time.